so if you're out there you're in if
you're out there you wouldn't you're not
out there you won't be listening to this
but since you're out there you're in one
of two or three camps I suspect most
people have some level of fear if we
want to downgrade it all the way into
concern I have concerns I don't have a
lot of fears but I have some concerns
right now and some of you have fears and
concerns about coronavirus and you're
you're worried about your health you're
worried about the health of the nation
if you have a medical issue that you're
recovering from a member of your family
that is or you're elderly and
susceptible in the high-risk group that
is a valid concern now just like the flu
is a valid concern for you it could take
you out and so the the virus could be
fatal in that situation we all know that
now we've all talked about that and we
all know that the vast majority of the
deaths almost all of them have been in
those categories and so almost all of
the folks that were healthy previous to
getting the virus have had full
recoveries so we know that now and so
there's are some facts but people are
pretty freaked out about the virus and
the pandemic and the World Health
Organization has now footing in our
psychology that never had before it has
the CDC has footing and credibility in
our minds that it never had before
superseding that of governments even in
some of your minds and people have gone
a little crazy some of you are afraid
more afraid now of the cure this
everyone stays at home and does nothing
so the economy completely implodes 4 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 weeks
how many weeks of that can this economic
system that we've built endure how many
weeks of that can your family endure how
many we
of that can your small business endure
and so you're afraid so let me first
just tell you as Uncle Dave or Papa Dave
or whatever you want to call it I'm
gonna be a little parental I'm often
that so if you're not used to that get
over it when people are afraid some of
you are misbehaving you're being mean to
other people and you need to stop that
you're being mean to other family
members inside your family because your
fear is out of control and you need to
calm your butt down and behave some of
you are misbehaving a friend of mine was
in Walgreens and stepped across some
blue mythical line in there that has
something to do with social distancing
and some twerp and skinny jeans yelled
at her stop that you're misbehaving your
fear is causing you to misbehave calm
down my friends on maximal often says
that hurting people hurt people and so
you're scared and now your fear you're
doing harm to other people and you need
to stop it you need to be kind the
number of mean nasty threatening
horrible things that have been said
about me in the past seven days is off
the scale well I can handle it but it
just reveals you it doesn't reveal me my
character didn't change a week ago my
character has always been exactly what
my character is I've never been greedy
capitalistic horrible put people in
harm's way for a dollar I've never done
that in 30 years and there's no evidence
to that fact and yet I've been accused
of all of those things because some of
your just meaner than crud because
you're scared I was growing up I had a
little dog that was a Boston Terrier I
love those little Bulldogs named Mugsy
when I was a little guy I was about
seven years old Mugsy guy ran in front
of a golf ball as my neighbor was
swinging practicing drive
in the backyard hit Mugsy in the head
knocked her out when she came back
around she was in shock and he brought
her up and put her in the front yard and
the dog was trying to bite everything
because it was in shock well I am my
naivete thought I could just run over
and little Mugsy who slept in my bed
every night and little Davey would be
best buddies and that dog was gettin
right ere my arm off and my dad or one
of the neighbourhood men grabbed me and
pulled me back before and they threw a
dog threw a blanket over that dog and
took it to the vet and it never again
liked golf balls after it came back
around but that's when I first learned
that even things that you love when
they're afraid and wounded will hurt you
you need to stop being one of those
everybody start being a little nicer
find someone you can leave an extra big
tip with find someone you can just smile
at they're afraid some of them and
they're more afraid some of them than
they've ever been in their adult lives
because they've never really faced a
crisis before some of these youngsters
have never faced a real hard time for
them the hard time was that the battery
on their cell phone was running low and
they need your mercy in your love and
you need to be kind I don't care what
you do to me I'm gonna be kind to you
I'm gonna love every one of you I'm
gonna give you a big ol hug and I'm
gonna help you and I'm gonna block you
on Twitter if you're a [ __ ] so this is
what we're gonna do for the next couple
hours John you ready I loved every
second of it yeah so we'll take some
calls those of you that have questions
about fear and anxiety but I think some
kindness is in order I think some people
need to top order top of the line
everywhere just be kind yeah
just stop it stop it be kind it's not
it's not our nature to do that when
we're in trouble that's right our nature
is to lash out that's right and some of
these people are showing that they have
the emotional maturity of a
four-year-old and they're functioning at
that level and the things you say on
Twitter the things you say on Instagram
the things you say to your own family
you ought to be ashamed of yourself
gotta be ashamed of yourself
Phoebe nice start right now be kind
spread kindness everywhere everywhere
I'm hugs I don't you listen you want
social distancing better stay away from
me cuz I'm gonna hug you come here John